FERGUS HURLEY: Hi.
I'm Fergus Hurley, a
product manager at Google.
Thorough testing is
an essential part
of building a
high-quality app or game.
But the process can be time
consuming and frustrating.
That's why we've
added new features
to our pre-launch report to
make basic app testing a breeze.
So what is the
pre-launch report?
It's a helpful dashboard
within the Google Play Console
that alerts you of any
quality concerns in your app
before it affects your users.
Whenever you upload an app
to the closed or open testing
tracks in the
Google Play Console,
you'll automatically
generate this free report.
The report is created from an
automated crawl of your app,
using the tools and
infrastructure of Firebase Test
Lab.
The crawler, which we call
Robo, explores your app
by inputting taps,
swipes, and text.
Tests are run on a wide
range of devices of varying
specs and price points.
Once your app has been
crawled, within an hour,
the pre-launch report
flags any crashes,
security vulnerabilities,
startup time issues,
or other problems.
On the Overview page, you'll
find clear recommendations
on how to address the results.
You'll also see a summary of
the issues found by the crawler.
It even offers
suggestions of taking
advantage of the report's
more advanced features.
We'll come back to
that in a moment.
Below that, you'll see the
full details of everything
the crawler found, including
screenshots and videos
taken during the crawl.
These are great for
spotting UX issues
by seeing what the crawler was
doing when your app crashed.
We've also added information
about accessibility
and usability issues,
like small-touch targets,
poor contrast, and missing or
confusing voice annotations.
While the pre-launch report is
useful in its default state,
you can easily customize
it to focus on the things
that matter most to your app.
For example, while Robo
can crawl any app built
on the Android framework,
what if your app or game
uses OpenGL?
In that case, you can use
demo loops or monkey actions.
A demo loop lets you
create automated journeys
through your app.
So if you're testing
a game, you might
configure it to focus on a
particular level or character.
To run a demo loop, first
add the loop to your game,
then modify your game to
launch and run the demo loop.
Finally, declare the demo
loop in your apps manifesto.
Now, when you run a test, the
crawler will use the demo loop.
When the crawler
is finished, you'll
see both the
standard test results
and any rendering issues so you
can investigate any problems
with frame rates.
A monkey action let's
the crawler test
actions in places where you
haven't provided demo loop.
In this case, when the crawler
reaches an OpenGL canvas,
it'll perform random
taps and swipes.
While it doesn't have the
sophistication of a demo loop,
it can detect issues you
didn't encounter in your test.
And what if your app asks
for users to sign in?
No problem.
The crawler can test the
logged in experience too.
If you Sign-in with
Google, the crawler
can locate the
log-in button and use
the Google account
that's already
included on the test device.
If your app uses a
custom sign-in mechanism,
just configure the pre-launch
report with a test account.
Go to Settings and enter the
resources used for the username
and password fields as
well as the log-in button.
You'll also enter the test
username and password.
Now when the crawler
encounters your log-in button,
you'll enter the test account
details and keep testing.
The pre-launch report can also
test up to three deep links.
Deep links take users right
to the specific feature
in your app, skipping
the usual entry flow.
To specify which deep links you
want to test, go to Settings
and just add the URLs.
The crawler will run
for about five minutes,
then close your app and
visit each deep link
for about 30 seconds each.
If it finds any issues,
you'll see them in the report.
What if you want
even more control?
Maybe your app has a
sign-up screen early
in the onboarding flow
that you need to test
or you want the
crawler to access
a specific part of your app.
That's where robo
scripts come in.
Robo scripts are a sequence of
actions recorded in JSON file.
To record a script, open
Android Studio, go to Tools,
and open Firebase.
Click Record Robo Script and
use it to guide robo test, then
Record Robo Script.
Select the test device
and record the steps
you want the crawler
to follow and save
the robo script to file.
Now go to the pre-launch
report and upload your script
under Settings.
The next time you
run the crawler,
it'll open your robo script
and follow the sequence
of steps you recorded
before returning
to its default crawling pattern.
The pre-launch report
can also be configured
to test in any language.
By default, it will test
the most popular languages
among your users.
But you may want to test out a
new version before launching it
with a new language.
To test in another language,
open the pre-launch report
settings anytime after the
initial crawl of your app.
You can define up
to five languages
to test when you
upload a new version.
The pre-launch
report is a great way
to do a final quality check
after your own QA testing,
helping you deliver higher
quality apps and games.
Everyone who publishes APKs
to the closed or open testing
tracks can get a
pre-launch report.
Just open the
Google Play Console
to get your free report.
Check it out next time you're
uploading a pre-production app.
Thanks for watching.